late last week we saw arguably the
biggest news so far in the Trump Russia
scandal investigation we learned that
special prosecutor Robert Muller has
impaneled a grand jury
you don't impanel a grand jury unless
it's at least realistic that crimes were
committed and Trump continues to call
the entire thing a hoax I think he did
that in West Virginia late last week
when he was welcoming former Democratic
West Virginia governor to the Republican
Party Jim Justice switching from
Democrat to Republican grand juries
don't investigate hoaxes I hate to break
it to Donny boy they don't investigate
conspiracy theories there are very
specific rules for when and how a grand
jury can be used and there are right
wing commentators that are saying oh
molar is going on a fishing expedition
just to see what a grand jury might
uncover wrong grand juries cannot be
used that way a grand jury is put in
place because molars investigation has
reached the point of having evidence
that points to criminal conduct that
doesn't mean criminal conduct 100% took
place it doesn't mean that it would be
100% prosecutable but it means there is
evidence that exists that points to
crimes that doesn't mean Pat that
indictments will necessarily happen but
this is not a fishing expedition this is
the logical progress of a very serious
investigation
it just seems like every bit of news
that's come out of this investigation or
the Russia probe overall has been
heading in one direction yes and whether
it's the Jared Kushner back channel
whether it's James Comey being fired or
the John Jr meeting and then you get to
the point where robert muller is
appointed as the special counsel he is
going to be looking into you know having
a grand jury I mean this is all going in
one place and the other thing I want to
mention is even though it made major
headlines that there is a grand jury
looking into whether the President of
the United States illegally colluded
with a foreign nation to obtain the Oval
Office to win the presidency its major
news at the same time it's not that
surprising because once you put in a
special prosecutor you're already doing
that because of what the circumstances
point to so even though it's major news
that there's a grand jury
of historic proportions it's not
altogether surprising and Ryan Lizza in
The New Yorker wrote that in the Clinton
email case a grand jury was impaneled to
issue some subpoenas we've recently
learned that but it never led to
indictment so there's no guarantee that
a grand jury is going to lead to
indictment but the fact that we had a
grand jury in the first place already
told us it's there's not nothing here it
is pretty telling especially if you look
at there the fact that there's a second
grand jury looking into Michael Flynn
over in Eastern Virginia that's right
based on his connection to a Turkish
businessman so is that one not going
anywhere either oh I guess we'll have to
wait and see and then it could all go on
for months or years and Newt Gingrich is
now saying the location of the grand
jury is a problem it's a DC grand jury
and Washington DC votes very democratic
and Newt Gingrich tweeted a couple of
days ago when it leaked or when it was
announced rather or revealed that there
was a grand jury Newt Gingrich tweeted
president Trump got 68 percent of the
vote in West Virginia and 4.8% in
Washington DC
guess where Moeller has a grand jury
guess how biased it will be sadly for
Newt you don't get to choose where you
are investigated Donald Trump is
President of the United States his
possible crimes are looked at by our
national intelligence and law
enforcement agencies and that's in
Washington DC but remember Bill Clinton
was impeached Democratic Bill Clinton
was impeached in liberal-leaning
Washington DC and there's one other
element of this Trump has previously
talked about his red line on Robert
Muller's investigation saying if Muller
starts looking into the Trump business
dealings that might cross some kind of a
red line for Trump we've now heard from
Assistant Attorney General rod Rosen
Stein who has confirmed what we all knew
which is that a special counsel can
investigate any crimes they uncover in
the Russia probe period if they go in
because of Trump Russia collusion and
what they find is obstruction of justice
related to the cover-up that is fair
game however if it goes further and what
they find is international money
laundering or domestic tax fraud as I'll
talk to you about later in the show it's
all fair game Pat and even though Trump
talks about this red line he
even the assistant attorney general says
Muller has wide discretion here
especially if you look at the precedent
that the Republicans set in the 90s
where a whitewater investigation into
Bill Clinton ended on a staining dress
with Monica Lewinsky exactly right and
there there are many differences between
the current investigation and what Ken
Starr was doing under Clinton's time but
the point is there is very very wide
range that is provided to these special
prosecutors lastly it looked like Trump
was sort of cocked on Twitter I mean I
hate I don't want to use such an
inappropriate term gotta be used it's
got to be used here it seems that since
new chief of staff John Kelly joined
after the firing a rather and
immediately affected the firing of
Anthony Scotto Moochie it seemed like
Trump's tweeting was being kept under
control and maybe it's because he's on
the 17-day golf the case of a Haitian we
don't know we we were not really hearing
from Trump on Twitter but then this
morning he exploded again on Twitter and
it was after senator dick Blumenthal
said something about Trump Russia
collusion and and Trump just couldn't
resist starting to talk about Vietnam
and all sorts of other stuff related to
Blumenthal and again on CNN on MSNBC
this morning the talk was once again
returning to Donald Trump's Twitter so
if it was Kelly that was keeping Trump
under control
cocking him in terms of his access to
social media it seems to have ended
Trump's back on Twitter maybe he could
control him for like a week or so but
it's like a pressure cooker I mean at
some point the things going to explode
last thing I want to say on this and you
kind of alluded to this Pat earlier
we've continued to see the Russia Trump
Russia collusion story move forward
despite hearing from countless people
that there's no story everything is all
fake it's a witch hunt it's going to go
away we only see forward progress we
only learn more we see more and more
aspects of the Trump Russia blackmail
dossier confirmed I can't think of one
moment so far Pat where we've had to say
oh you know what this big area of
allegations regarding Trump Russia it
was all wrong let's back up we've gone
too far that's never happened the
progress has been faster at some moments
and slower at other moments but it all
moving forward and that's what is so
stunning to me when I hear from both the
left and right that there's no story
here if there isn't why do we learn more
and more every week and we get closer
and closer to proving that there was
collusion which we now have some
evidence of in writing I mean people who
deny this may point to the fact that
Trump attacked the Syrian air base but
of course he let the Russians know
before they did that yeah and also you
know the sanctions that have now been
levied on Russia he couldn't really get
out of that situation I mean Congress
passed that so overwhelmingly those are
the two points people point to they say
listen if Trump is so in bed with Russia
why did he bombed that Syrian air base
of course he warned Russia about it and
that air base was back up and running
within hours and number two will trump
signed off on new sanctions against
Russia yet Trump really had no choice he
could have done nothing and they would
have been enacted anyway he could have
vetoed that them which would have been
completely jumping the shark at this
point in proving that he is completely a
puppet of Vladimir Putin he really had
no choice and if those are the only two
things you can point to there's like 10
things on the other side that Trump has
done that are exactly what Vladimir
Putin would want send me your thoughts
am I missing something and I just
clueless about this entire thing because
I'm some kind of shill I know you'll
tweet me about that I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman today's program is made possible
in part by Beachbody on demand which is
an online Fitness streaming service that
gives you unlimited access to many
highly effective world-class workouts
personalized to meet your needs you can
actually stream over 600 different
workouts from programs that deliver
really great results this includes piyo
p90x
you also get a bunch of other great
nutritional content for foods recipes
cooking programs etc you also have
step-by-step program guides and workout
calendars and I've actually tried my
girlfriend has been using some of these
programs for several years and I've
tried some of them recently and it's
some of them are brutal but it really is
great great stuff and whether you want
high impact low impact whatever some
days I feel more like cardio some days
more like strength whatever the case may
be
there's just unlimited options seemingly
unlimited options and this is a brand
new sir
is already over a million members and
you can get a free trial membership when
you text Pakman PA que ma n to 30 30 30
okay so you get full access to the
platform for free when you text PA que
ma n 2 30 30 30